[suspenseful music]
♪ ♪
Hey, man.
Psst.
What you using that Bitcoin for?
- Just to, like, buy stuff.
- What are you really
using it for?
- Mo--like, money.
- Hey, so what
do you use Bitcoin for?
- You know,
just try to invest it.
Uh, I heard, you know,
it's gonna increase in value.
- I use it mostly
as an investment,
but, uh, you know,
I use it for online tipping
and small purchases and stuff.
- There's a lot of things you
could use it for, to be honest.
- Yeah?
- You could buy a polar bear.
[laughter]
- You ever bought a polar bear?
- No,
but I tried to get
a mail-order-bride once.
- Is that for real?
- I didn't go through with it
'cause it was kind of fishy.
- Hey, man,
what do you use Bitcoin for?
- I don't really wanna talk
about it on camera.
- Okay, you can tell me though.
What are you really buying?
- [distorted]
I, uh, stream soccer.
- Wait, this whole anonymity
thing was about soccer?
- [distorted]
Illegal soccer streams
from overseas.
- Yeah, I get it.
You're a gangster.
You don't use it
to buy stuff on the dark web?
- No.
- You could be getting
all this cool stuff.
- I do get cool stuff.
- Like what?
- Like video games, shoes...
- So people think
this is all spooky weirdness
because it's all cryptocurrency?
It's like a peer-to-peer system
where you have different,
uh, servers that are verifying
transactions with each other,
but, like,
a private corporation,
I'm talking
about the Federal Reserve.
- I've never been
on the dark web.
- Do you know what kind of stuff
you could get on there?
- Nope.
- That Sticky Icky Icky,
uh, Bubba Diesel nugs,
Moon Rocks,
retrovil pills,
ecstasy, molly--
same thing.
Is it?
There's Honey Hash,
there's dabs.
Gorilla Glue,
Blueberry Diesel bud,
500 grams of Colombian
fishscale cocaine.
- Half the amount of Bitcoin
is algorithmically based
depending on the time...
- Mushrooms,
acid, mashrooms,
uh, grenade launchers,
a bow and arrow,
uh, just a bow,
uh, for, like, a young girl.
If you have a daughter,
you could buy her a bow,
put it in her hair.
- Sure.
- Suffice to say,
it's all encrypted.
So usually, that's, like,
an amalgamation of a bunch...
- TCB, 2CB, QCB, QVC.
You see "Shark Tank."
Lori, she's the queen of that.
- Quick tangent
on other cryptocurrencies.
You know, a central bank--
- Uh, I just wanna buy weed.
I just wanna buy weed.
That's why I'm here.
- I got a guy.
- All right, let's go.
Yeah, let's take off.
This way?
- Yes.
- Cool.
[soft music]
[cheers, laughter, and applause]